so I think that what Shawn did with
showing how burrows-wheeler can be
applied to pattern matching is really
awesome but I'd like to point out that
we're kind of back at an issue that we
had when we were using the suffix tree
which is that he's been able to identify
whether or not each pattern occurs in
the genome using the burrows-wheeler
transform but remember that the multiple
pattern matching problem says we need
also find their positions okay we need
to know where it is that these that
pattern matches are happening okay so
the question then is can we use
burrows-wheeler transform to reveal
these positions if we go back to our
example we know that a a occurs three
times in panama bananas but if we're
using burrows-wheeler and we just have
the first in the last column we don't
know where it is that these pattern
matches are occurring so we'll use to
help us out we're going to use a data
structure called a suffix array and this
is going to hold the starting position
of each suffix beginning a row what do I
mean by a suffix beginning a row well
each row of the burrows-wheeler
transform corresponds to a cyclic
rotation of our original string okay so
if it's a cyclic rotation then that
means that you can walk to some point
and reach the dollar sign and that
walking corresponds to a suffix so the
first row is just the dollar sign so
it's the suffix that ends the string and
that's in position 13 so we put a 13 on
that row the next row begins with a
bananas and the a bananas is in position
0 1 2 3 4 5 starting position 5 of the
original string so we put a 5 in the
second element of the suffix array and
we go through this so amiable Anas is in
position 3 and so on so we get 1 7 9 and
so on so we reconstruct the entire
suffix array this way and so now we have
this suffix array so how is it helpful
to threads to find the matches well if
we look at the three occurrences of a a
that we found we just say what are the
corresponding elements of the suffix
array and this tells us that a a occurs
at positions 1 7 & 9 of
bananas so suffix array values are 1 7 &
9 and here is starting position 1 7 & 9
which we saw before the issue though is
I know what Shaun will say which is how
much memory is it that the suffix array
took and this is an issue in fact if you
represent integers as using 4 bytes then
the memory is going to be on the order
of 4 times the length of genome so when
we use the suffix tree we had about 20
times the length of genome now maybe
we're down to about four times the links
of length of genome to store the suffix
array and that's better in fact the
suffix array is hiding in the suffix
tree that we were working with before
remember we labeled the nodes of the
suffix tree with the starting position
of the suffix that ended at that at that
leaf and if we do what's called an
inorder traversal of the suffix tree
then we can reconstruct these the suffix
array by going down to five and then so
we go sort of down into the left as much
as possible at each step so we go down
into the left as much as we can and we
hit 5 then 5 stakin so we go down and we
go the next node over so that's 3 then
then we go down and then we can't go to
these 2 nodes but we go here and then we
go left so that gives us 1 and so on so
we if we traverse the tree in this
manner and go down to the leaves then
we're able to see this correspondence
that the suffix array is hiding in the
suffix tree
okay so then the question would be now
that we have now we have a data
structure of burrows-wheeler which is
about the length of genome now we have
the suffix array which is about 4 times
the length of genome maybe and the
question would be can we get this down
to approximately the length of genome
can we shorten it even more right and
that's what I hope Shawn will be able to
tell us about in the next section